ceci est un cerveau chaque jour nous
produisons vous avez combien de pincer
ont produit par jour en un produit 60
milles et sur ses soixante mille on en
produit 48000 qui sont négatives
c'est à dire 4 sur 5 c'est trop de
pensées négatives et ça nous empêche
d'avancer
voilà l'objectif c'est d'avoir le plus
de pensée positive possible à une
meilleure machinerie optimiste
voilà afin que ce cerveau il est tout
mou il est mal foutu mais il nous a
permis de faire de grandes choses
le cerveau a des propriétés étonnantes
et copropriétés il a averti cité qu'est
ce que la plasticité la passivité c'est
par exemple quand je jouais du piano
quand je fais une activité des réseaux
de neurones s'activent
voilà et quand je pratique - seule
activité les réseaux de neurones ont
tendance à s'affaiblir et le cerveau
s'adapte les zones du cerveau s'adapte
andy qui les plastiques c'est cela la
plasticité du cerveau et nous allons
jouer sur la plasticité du cerveau pour
qu' il se transforme en véritable
machine optimiste
une véritable machine de guerre ou
plutôt de paix voilà c'est plutôt ça
qu'on veut alors
c est arnaud rubik c'est notre premier
exemple alors pourquoi je vous parlais
de erno rubik l'huile à extérioriser
tous que nous allons voir dans les autre
exemple il a réussi à extérioriser
qu'est ce que c'est que extérioriser
extérioriser ses maîtres à l'extérieur
ce que dans le cerveau on imagine on
conçoit des machines on a inventé la
roue on a inventé l'intelligence
artificielle on a inventé plein d'autres
choses de machines et à partir de là on
réussit à faire des prouesses jeu outré
pourquoi les mathématiques steve à vous
public et vous vous la télévision ou
plutôt sur route ou sur des knicks voilà
je vais vous montrer à vous pourquoi les
mathématiques c'est important et
pourquoi ça sauver des vies
l'extériorisation c'est bien sûr m à
l'extérieur et lui il a mis à
l'extérieur
un concept l'algorithme l'algorithme y
en a partout
on a des algorithmes partout dans notre
quotidien on en parle mais qu'est ce que
c'est un algorithme et bien c'est lui
était professeur d'algorithmique
algorithmes professeur en cours à erno
rubik et ses étudiants ne comprenait pas
trop les les
les algorithmes c'était un peu fumeux
bon bref alors il a visualisé il a
extériorisé il a créé sa il a créé et ça
c'est un mouvement
ça c'est un mouvement ça c'est un autre
mouvement à notre mouvement notre
mouvement c'est une succession de
mouvements athées sont inversés c'est
une succession de mouvements une
succession mouvement une succession
d'opérations
c'est cela un algorithme alors les
algorithmes ont servi dans l'histoire de
l'humanité les algorithmes ne sont pas
si jeune que ça on les utilise en
arithmétique depuis la nuit des temps
en mathématiques alors pourquoi et
mathématiques
les baptêmes
tic sa véritable puissance optimiste
positif sur le monde un véritable impact
il pince et créer quelque chose de
positif lui
alan turing allons c'est lui alors si
c'est pas les britanniques c'est pas les
russes c'est pas les espagnols c'est une
personne c'est lui qui a sauvé des
millions de vies
il a arrêté une guerre grâce à la
puissance des mathématiques avec ses
algorithmes il a créé une machine très
puissante pour décrypter le code nazis
et mettre en place une stratégie pour
contrer le bal et grâce à lui on a pu
déchiffrer et arrêter la guerre l'arrêté
des larmes du sang a été permis grâce à
cet homme-là grâce à la puissance de feu
des mathématiques vous vous rendez
compte dans les mathématiques
voilà à quoi ça sert ça sert à sauver
des millions de vies et à arrêter une
guerre ou à l'écourter et à propos de
guerre un exemple proche
je suis le petit fils de grands parents
qui ont connu la guerre d'espagne
vous voyez souffrent qu il y avait garni
qu'à garni car ils ont connu les
bombardements
ils ont tout perdu ils ont tout perdu
matériellement mais ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont eu ce qu'ils ont gardé ce qui
leur a donné la force de vivre c'est
l'optimisme
ils se sont soudés c'est l'amour qui
leur a donné la force
c'est l'union qui leur a donné à force
de tout reconstruire et de vouloir aller
à république ici en france voilà ils ont
y franco c'est grâce à leur potentiel
optimiste et j'espère que vous prendront
acte de tout cela intelligence
artificielle on en parle un peu partout
dans les journaux d'un plusieurs media
intelligence artificielle est un outil
qui nous permet de faire face aux grands
défis aux grands problèmes majeurs de ce
siècle que ce soit allé le racisme les
guerres les maladies l'extinction de
masse l'une des plus grandes d
extinction de toute l'histoire de la vie
sur la terre c'est grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle que nous
ferons face aux défis majeurs de ce
siècle est déjà sorti
ciel coran m mais elle permet des
solutions rationnelles
il ya des solutions qui sont rationnels
grâce aux mathématiques grâce aux
algorithmes encore une fois encore une
fois l'intelligence artificielle grâce
aux algorithmes va nous permettre de
relever tous ces défis
c'est une véritable allié pour notre
machinerie est optimiste on a réussi à
extérioriser puisque on a réussi à
penser à créer pensée s'est créé on a
extériorisé encore une fois de plus un
concept encore un autre exemple le
célébre spurs ne sais pas si vous vous
connais alors les whispered alors la
funk la naissance de la feuq fin que ça
veut dire
transpiration pourquoi alors la funk qui
a donné de nouvelles musiques
aujourd'hui que ce soit l'électro le hip
hop d'autres musiques actuelles ça a
beaucoup influencé à la base c'était des
gens qui transpirait il avait des moyens
au bide humanitaire il se dit bt on n'a
pas d'orchestre on va prendre un piano
et on va mettre de la musique un peu
plus dynamique
on va adapter le jazz soul et c est à
partir de là on crée une nouvelle
musique qui est de notre propre corps
qui donne un propre âme
c'est à feu voilà ils ont été dénigrés
par des racistes à mais voilà il
transpire tout ça c'est la fin que voilà
eh bien oui on s'appelle fuck
voilà et eux ils ont eu le courage de
à force de créer ce nouveau type de
musique et qui maintenant est partout
hormis la musique classique
le reste c'est majoritairement de perth
coulées de gravats
d'autres exemples bien nous avons vu des
exemples forts que d'impacter sur le
monde
nous allons vue l'intelligence
artificielle qui peut apporter des qui
déjà une extériorisation du cerveau nous
avons vu que les mathématiques arrive à
sauver des vies et en corse c'est que là
je pense que ce sera encore le cas on va
sauver le plus de vies possibles à
muscles à nos réseaux de neurones
optimiste on va finir par trouver les
solutions et ainsi à sauver le monde
pourquoi pas contre l'extinction de
masse contre tous les problèmes il faut
que nous soyons soudée voilà il faut
qu'il y ait de l'amour de la solidarité
sur cette terre il faut voilà beaucoup
de valeurs humaines l'humanisme
nous avons besoin d'humanisme
d'optimisme il faut des chercheurs des
ingénieurs des artistes
il faut qu'on se retrouve et qu'on face
aux problèmes les plus importants les
plus faibles des fois effrayant eh bien
on arrive quand même à trouver des
solutions des solutions fortes efficace
voilà et c'est gras
cette pincée c'est grâce à nos pensées
c'est grâce à cette machine c'est pour
l'instant la machine la plus puissante
que nous avons que nous arriverons à
faire face à tous ces problèmes
ceci est un cerveau un cerveau optimiste
et n'oubliez pas penser c'est créer
[Applaudissements]